welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is bonus day two
and we're gonna learn from the sixth
richest person on the planet at the time
of this recording with a net worth of
107.4
billion dollars mr warren buffett was
wondering how you define success
personally
well i i can certainly define happiness
because that's what
that's what i am i mean i i and if that
i mean i get to do what i like to do
every single day of the year and i get
to do it with people i like
and i get to the i get to i don't have
to associate with anybody causes my
stomach to churn
and uh the only thing in my job i don't
like and this only happens about every
three or four years
occasionally i have to fire somebody and
i don't like that's the only thing
other than i tap dance to work and i get
down there and i think i'm supposed to
lie on my back and paint the ceiling you
know or something like microwaves i mean
that's the way i feel and it doesn't
diminish
it it's it's tremendous fun so uh
you know if uh they say that uh
uh success is uh uh uh getting what you
want and happiness is wanting what you
get
well i don't know which one applies in
this case but i
i do know that i i wouldn't be doing
anything else i mean
uh i do advise you you know when you go
out to work go to work for an
organization that you admire
people you admire because it'll it'll
it'll turn you on and and
you ought to be happy where you are
working and i always worry about people
who
say you know i'm going to do this for 10
years i really don't like it very well
then i'll do 10 more years of this
i mean that's a little like saving up
sex for your old age i mean
not not a very good idea
so get right in recommend that get ready
get right
get right into what you enjoy you know
and and
and you'll be successful at it you
really will i mean you won't be able to
miss
and uh um you know that's uh
uh i don't regard what i do as the most
important thing in the world at all but
it's right for me i mean i happen to be
wired in a certain way that what i do
works in this if i had to do what
you know bill does i mean it lasts about
10 minutes
and that's true of a lot of things but i
luckily i kind of stumbled into the
thing that i
i do best and and that you know that
it's worked out well
warren is probably the most rational
person i've ever met
charlie munger would be a close rival
and charlie became a man that warren
depended on
heavily and i think his first
experiences in the discarded cigar but
era
convinced him that it was not exactly
where he wanted to be
he'd made so much money for so long
doing what he'd been taught by ben
graham
which should buy these very cheap stocks
if they were cheap enough he didn't care
it was a lousy company and lousy
management he knew he was going to make
money anyway just because of the
cheapness
charlie munger has had a big impact on
me in
moving me toward looking for wonderful
companies at fair prices
rather than fair companies at wonderful
prices and that was enormously important
because it enabled berkshire to scale up
in a way that would have been impossible
to do otherwise
yep what are the key indicators you look
for within companies before making
an investment well i look for something
that does give them a motor rod
we have a company called sea's candy out
on the west coast sea's cat is
box chocolates if you give a box
of sea chocolates to your girlfriend on
the first date
and she kisses you we own you
you know we we can raise the price
tomorrow and you'll buy the same box
you're not going to fool her out with
success so the key there is the response
you do not want to go home on
valentine's day and say to your wife or
your sweetheart
preferably they're the same person you
don't say here honey
i took the low bid it doesn't work price
is
to a degree is immaterial if you've got
a economic castle
people are going to come and want to
take that castle away from you and you
better have a
strong moan you better have a nightmare
castle that knows what he's doing
you're not buying an asset you're buying
a name you're buying a brand you're
buying a
real franchise here and
charlie was more responsible for that
than anybody
[Music]
we were metal partners right from the
moment we met
i want to know going back 50 years what
it was like when you first
met warren well i thought he was a
prodigy
and i got a lot of criticism my wife
said why are you paying such enormous
respect to that young man with a crew
cut
who won't eat vegetables
he's ungodly smart he's got a much
broader intellect than i do
and he's magnificent at being able to
condense important ideas into
just a very few words if you're not
interested in the economic
scene right now you're mentally dead
charlie has no tax all right let's talk
a little bit about bankers
charlie on friday compared them to
heroin addicts
yeah well that's colorful charlie but i
would not have chosen that
i once wrote of him that when they
handed out humility
he didn't get his fair share the ideal
way to run a headquarters is to have
one man preferably over 80
sitting in an office by himself
[Music]
anything else is pure flippery
he's always honest than what he tells me
so i i listened to him
[Music]
[Applause]
we never had an argument we just
we just kind of roll with it easily
suppose warren doesn't want to do
something that i would have done
and suppose that happens four times over
40 years or something
what the hell difference does it make to
me
[Applause]
net the record is working out fine
both of us know that we've done better
by having
ethics warren's not interested in making
money by cheating people
warren's opinions of wall street
investment bankers
would not endear him to their mothers
he feels that they're for the most part
not out for their clients
they're out for their own business
interests
in the late 1960s there were just a
flood of
accounting shenanigans and mergers built
upon false accounting and misleading
people
it was a time when a lot of charlatans
were prevailing in wall street and were
being applauded by wall street and
i understood what the game was about but
i didn't want to play in it
so i closed down the partnership at the
end of 1969
and i took on the title of chairman for
the berkshire hathaway
you haven't bought the stock you're an
admirer of jeff bezos a listing of the
richest people in america came out he's
number one i think your friend bill
gates is number two you're number three
so you can see what he's done in myriad
ways
and of course the question is how come
you haven't bought amazon is there still
time to buy would you still
buy it well i i always admired jeff i
mean i met him
20 years ago or so and and and
i thought it was something special but i
didn't realize you could go from books
to what
what's happened there no i i mean he had
a vision
and executed in an incredible way
something that
it would not have you know that
but there's a lot of games i miss i
would have missed you know i would have
missed microsoft even if i got to know
bill
earlier or something those just aren't
my games i don't worry about the things
that
i miss that are outside my circle of
competence
of evaluating i i do i have missed
things that were
within my circle and that's a terrible
mistake
those are my biggest mistakes you
haven't seen them and
but i don't it's not a mistake because i
miss netscape or something
like that at all i would say that maybe
five percent of the companies or ten
percent of the companies at most
are within an area my circle of
confidence there's something i should
be able to understand i would like to
tell you of
two women uh that
each sold the business to berkshire
hathaway
uh to me actually for many many many
millions of dollars
both of them started with twenty five
hundred dollars by a coincidence was the
exact same amount it was
everything they had in the world and one
of them
was a woman who landed in seattle
in 1917 couldn't speak a word of english
had a tag around her neck the tag said
uh fort dodge iowa
the red cross got her to fort dodge
where she was reunited with her
husband who had come to the country a
couple of years earlier
and she lived in fort dodge for two
years and as she put it
she felt like a dummy she couldn't pick
up the language she couldn't learn a
word
and so she decided she and her husband
decided
to move to omaha so they came to omaha
in 1919 and
there she found a small colony of
russian jews so she started feeling more
at home
and then as her oldest daughter went to
school
she would come home this daughter
francis
and she would teach her mother the words
she learned in school
that day and this woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years saving money
bringing first her siblings over
her mother and father fifty dollars at a
time
she sold used clothing to do it she had
four children
during this period and by 1937
after 20 years she saved 2 500.
she went to chicago and she bought
what she could have furniture her dream
had always been to open
a furniture store and this woman would
who had never gone to school one day in
her life
with twenty five hundred dollars but
with the same spirit that the people in
this room had
about having a dream and working to
accomplish that dream
she built a business which she
sold to me in 1983 for
60 million dollars approximately in
which
which did a billion and a half dollars
worth of business last year
[Applause]
the fourth generation is working in that
business
this woman rose blumpkin lived
well she she worked for me until she was
103.
and then she said then she retired and
she died the next year which is a lesson
to all of berkshire's managers that
premature retirement you know nothing
you can't tell what's going to happen
but mrs b with her 2500 dollars
one further fact about her she could not
read or write and she went into a
furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she
brought a determination to succeed
she knew she could outwork anyone else
she knew she cared about her customers
she worked at very low gross margins but
she built this
incredible business somebody once said
that the
chains of habit are too light to be felt
until they're too heavy to be broken
i had been terrified of public speaking
i couldn't do it i'd throw
and i knew if i didn't cure it then i
never cured it
and so i saw an ad in the paper for the
dale carnegie course
which worked on developing your ability
to speak in public
and i went down there
a good smile has the same effect as a
puppy's tail
on a puppy they made us all these crazy
things to get out of ourselves and so we
stood on
tables and did all kinds of things
[Applause]
[Music]
if i hadn't have done that my whole life
would have been different
so in my office you will not see the
degree i got from the university of
nebraska
you'll not see the master's degree i got
from columbia university
but you'll see the little award
certificate i got from the dale carnegie
course how do i value the business
berkshire acquires well the first thing
i have to decide when somebody calls me
is is valuing this business within my
circle of competence
i don't know how to value microsoft i
don't know how to value oracle i mean if
you know larry ellison calls me or bill
gates calls me and they don't
but if any of those i don't know or
biotech or anything i wouldn't know how
to value it i just you know i'd wish
them well and
tell them you know i think it's worth
twice as much as they think it is but
i'm just not
in the mood to buy today uh i i don't
know
so it has to be within my circle of
confidence my circle of confidence is
you know
businesses i can understand and when i
say understand i don't mean to
understand how to use a computer and not
use a computer in terms of a computer
company
i mean understand what the economic
characteristics of the business are
and what the company's really going to
look like in five or 10 or 20 years
bill gates will tell you that that he
you know if
he were investing he would buy berkshire
rather than microsoft because
it's it's so much easier to understand
what our businesses are going to look
like whereas he's in a business where
you're going to really have to be doing
things differently over time
so i know that wrigley's is gonna be the
number one chewing gum
in the country i know stickers are gonna
be the number one candy bar in the
country 10 years from now
it's been the number one candy bar for
40 years you don't have to be
very bright to understand that when
people lay out 50 cents for something
that they stick in their mouth that
they're not about to experiment you know
i mean
it's so we we try to look at businesses
we can understand
i have an old-fashioned belief that i
can
only should expect to make money and
things that i understand and when i say
understand
i don't mean to understand you know what
the product does or anything like that
i mean understand what the economics of
the business
are likely to look at look like 10 years
from now or 20 years from now
i know in general what the economics
will say wrigley chewing gum will look
like
10 years from now the internet isn't
going to change the way people chew gum
it isn't going to change which gum they
chew you know if you
own the chewing gum market in a big way
and you've got double mint and spearmint
and juicy fruit
those brands will be there 10 years from
now so i can't
pinpoint exactly what the numbers are
going to look like on wrigley but i'm
not going to be way off if i try to look
forward on something like that
that evaluating that company is within
what i call my circle of competence i
understand
what they do i understand the economics
of it i understand the competitive
aspects
of the business figuring out the
economic consequences
tv i think there's i don't know 20 25
million cents a year sold in the united
states
i don't think there's one of them made
in the united states anymore i mean
you'd say tv set manufacturer what a
wonderful business i
everybody and nobody had a tv in 1950
they're about 45 to 50. everybody has
multiple sets now
but nobody in the united states has made
any real money making the sense they're
all out of business
you know the magna boxes the rca's all
of those companies
radio was the equivalent of the 20 over
500 companies making radios in the 1920s
again i don't think there's a
u.s radio manufacturer at the present
time but coca-cola
you know i was in 1884 jacob's pharmacy
or whatever
fellow comes up with something a lot of
copiers over the years
but now you've got a company that is
selling
roughly 1.1 billion eight ounce servings
of its product not all cokes brighton
some others
daily throughout the world 117 years
later so understanding
the economic characteristics of a
business is different
than predicting the fact that an
industry is going to do wonderfully
so when i look at the internet
businesses or i look at tech messages i
say this is a marvelous thing and i love
to play around with the computer and
i order my books from amazon and all
kinds of things but i don't know who's
going to win
unless i know who's going to win i'm not
interested in investing i'll just play
around on the computer
and defining your circle of competence
is the most important aspect of
investing
it's not how important how large your
circle is
you don't have to be an expert on
everything but knowing where the
perimeter of that circle of what you
know and what you don't know
is and staying inside of it is all
important
tom watson senior who started ibm
said in his book he said i'm no genius
he said but i'm smart in spots and i
stay around those spots
and you know that is the key uh so if i
understand a few things
and i stick in that arena i'll do okay
and if i don't understand something but
i get all excited about it because my
neighbors are talking about
stocks are going up and everything they
start fooling around someplace else
eventually i'll get cream and i should i
advise students
as much as possible look for the job
that you would take if you didn't need a
job
i mean you know don't sleep walk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great
you know i'll do this and i'll do that
and you know i'm just marking time to
get to be older that
i've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age i mean it just is
not
it it's not a good idea yeah
what are you urging them to do i'll
explain it
guess what i'm talking about
now it you just
yeah you really want to be doing what
you love doing
and you can't necessarily find it on
your first job right but
don't give up before you find it can you
help us understand
how to cultivate how to cultivate that
um mindset of being comfortable saying
no being comfortable delegating this is
something that
we found with our members is especially
difficult for young women
it's tough um and we'd love to just hear
your take on that and maybe any advice
you have to share about that
i met bill gates bill gates in 1991
and when i did it we had a great time
talking he thought he was going to hate
it and i
i wasn't too keen on it either and about
10 hours later we were still talking but
what really got him is when i pulled out
this little date book
i'm probably the only guy in the united
states with one of these still what the
oh no i have one over there
and i just flipped through it and you
know there's there's practically nothing
in it and bill was really impressed by
that and
uh you've got to keep control of your
time and and you won't
keep control of your time unless you can
say no ah you
you can't let other people set your
agenda in life and of course
i know i'm in a very fortunate position
on that because i can i
and in another way i'm not so fortunate
because more people ask me for things
and and and then they're usually friends
and they say well
can't you just make this one talk or
attend this one graduation or whatever
it may be
uh you know you've got to you just have
to develop the ability to say no and
and and uh do it a few times uh i mean
you know the woman can't say no she's in
trouble right
right and i mean is this something that
becomes easier over time or how did you
i don't think
it's a lot easier no it it's there's a
couple there's a few things that really
just aren't uncomfortable in life i've
the thing i like the the thing i dislike
the most
the the only thing i really dislike in
connection with my job is if i have to
fire somebody
i mean that does not get easy for the
easier for me as life has gone along
and saying no is not like firing people
but it's got a little bit of the same
aspect to it
it's not easy to say no particularly to
a friend
uh but i will have every day three or
four or five requests to do something
and i
i can't do them all you know and uh
but i'm not promising it gets easier but
but just keep doing it right otherwise
other people will be running your life
i got an awful lot of good advice from
my dad and
and he didn't he didn't lay it on me i
mean he just you know
you you picked it up from him but there
was never any of this you know do this
do that uh
type of thing at all but but i think he
really
taught me that it's more important uh in
terms of what's on your inner score card
than your outer score card i mean some
people
get in a position where they they're
thinking all of the time of what
what the world's going to think of this
or that instead of what they themselves
think about and if
if your inner score card if you're if
you're comfortable with that
uh i think you're going to going to have
a pretty happy life and i think the
people that strive too much for the
outer
score card sometimes find it it's a
little hollow when they get all through
how would you define true success
well i've i've said many times that that
if you get to be 65 or 70
and later and and the people that you
want to have
love you actually do love you you're a
success i've never seen anybody
that reaches that age i mean i'm not
talking about somebody that's in extreme
poverty or pain or something but i've
never seen anybody that if they have a
lot of people that love them
that is other than happy and i've seen
some very very
wealthy people that they give
testimonial dinners too and name schools
after and everything and they're
nobody nobody loves them by far the best
investment you can make is in yourself
i mean that for example communication
skills i tell the students that come
that
they're going to graduate schools and
business and they're learning all these
complicated formulas all that
if they just learn to communicate better
and both in writing and person
they increase their value at least fifty
percent and now i mean
uh if you can't communicate somebody who
says you know it's like winking at a
girl in the dark
nothing happens you know basically and
and you have to be able to get
get both your ideas and uh and that's
that's relatively easy i did it myself
with the dale carnegie of course
some people wish i'd taken a shorter
course now in terms of my talking later
on
but it it's just hugely important and
you if you invest in yourself
nobody can take it away from you i mean
you you and
uh the second thing which
i'll get a certain criticism for not
living it but but i do tell them
those students you know that if i gave
you a car and it'd be the only car
you're getting the rest of your life
you take care of it like you can't
believe any scratch you'd fix that
moment you read the owner's manual you
keep a garage and do all these things
and
you get exactly one mind of one and one
body in this world and
and you can't start taking care of it
when you're 50 by that time you'll
rush it out if you haven't done anything
so you you should
just really make sure that you just
remember that you just got one
mind and body to get through life with
and to do the most with it what about
life advice
well life advice is uh you know the most
important thing
uh aside from the things i've talked
about already
is is really who you associate with you
want to associate with people that are
better than you are
i mean basically you'll go in the
direction of the people that you
associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes uh
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
and when obviously you can't pick your
parents
uh they're gonna have an enormous
influence on you but you don't get a
choice on that but you get choices as
you go down the line and you
who you uh who you admire who you who
who you want to copy and the most
important
for most people in terms of that
decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business with the partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little
that's better than you are and then he
or she
and you hope they don't figure it out
too fast
70 years ago i was in high school
almost a third as long as the country
has been around
and when i was in high school i really
only had two things on my mind
girls and cars and
i wasn't doing very well with girls so
we'll talk about cars
but let's just imagine that when we
finish
i'm going to let each one of you pick
out
the car of your choice sounds good
doesn't it
pick it out any color you name it it'll
be tied up with a bow
and it'll be at your house tomorrow
and you say well what's the catch
and the catch is that it's the only car
you're going to get in your lifetime
now what are you going to do knowing
that that's the only car
you're ever going to have and you love
that car you're going to take care of it
like you cannot believe now what i'd
like to suggest
you're not going to get only one car in
your lifetime
but you're going to get one body and one
mind and that's all you're going to get
and that body and mind feels terrific
now
but it has to last you a lifetime people
ask me what they should take in business
school
and and and uh uh or even if they don't
go to business school what they need to
know before getting in business and i
tell them you know you have to
you have to understand accounting it's
the language i mean it would be
it's like being in a foreign country
without knowing the language if you're
in business and you don't understand
accounting so it
it you want to get as comfortable with
that
uh as you are with the english language
it
it's made me a lot of money because i
i listened to what ray dean had to say
53 or 4 years ago
and have been able to understand uh
what i was seeing on pieces of paper
what that told me about businesses and
the limitations of what it told me about
businesses
if you were to do it all over again
you're in our shoes
what industry would that be in where
would you start your own business today
i'd do the same thing yeah
no i mean i've had i had fun when i was
in my 20s my 30s now i'm 86 i'm having
fun
and so i i advise students as much as
possible
look for the job that you would take if
you didn't need a job
i mean you know don't sleep walk through
life and don't don't say it's all going
to be great
you know i'll do this and i'll do that
and you know i'm just marking time to
get to be older that
i've told people that's like saving up
sex for your old age i mean it just
is not it it's not a good idea
what are you urging them to do i'll
explain it
guess what i'm talking about that
now it it just
you really want to be doing what you
love doing
and you can't necessarily find it on
your first job right but
don't give up before you find it
everything you do learn is cumulative i
mean
that doesn't mean that industries stay
good forever or businesses take good
forever but but
learning to think about business models
what i learned at 20 is useful to me now
what i learned at 25 is useful to me now
and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes dramatically in terms of the
underlying principles it's like physics
i mean there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager
you know if he knows what makes a a good
product
uh and you learn that in one business
you can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and uh i don't think i can win every
game you know
somebody said how do you beat bobby
fischer you play him any game except
chess
so i don't play bobby fischer chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and
and learning what you're good at what
you're not good at i was wondering how
do you decide
what you invest your time and money in
yeah well i
i i like to find
businesses that have good economics now
what what are good economics well good
economics are a business that has
some kind of a moat around it that
makes its product or its service or its
location or something
a little more desirable into the
customer than any other sort of
comparable product
uh you know the number one candy bar in
the last 30 or 40 years has been
snickers
people don't fool around with different
candy bars they fool around with
different
length dresses they fool around you know
with all kinds of things but they don't
fool around with candy bars
because they figure you know they're
going to go in and lay out 50 cents or
whatever it is and put it in their mouth
and they're not going to for 50 cents
and putting in your mouth i mean you're
not going to say i'll
i'll put in i'll lay out 45 cents and
put something else in my mouth so
you find that very stable and we like
businesses
that we think we can figure out where
they're going to be in 10 or 15 years
i don't know where the information
technology businesses are going to be in
10 or 15 years i know where snickers
bars are going to be in 10 or 15 years
they're going to be selling just about
you know the way they do now i know
where wrigley's gum is going to be in 10
or 15 years
there's not going to be a lot of
innovation in in chewing them
uh the and p the internet's not gonna
cause people to quit chewing gum either
i mean at least
i mean gates may think so but i don't
think so but uh
uh it's it's predictability
regarding the sustainability of a
competitive advantage some something
special about a product
you don't need 150 iq to do what i do
thank god
you know you don't need 140 you know 135
you may need 115 or something like that
and and but you do need discipline you
have to wait
until you see the fat pitch to swing at
because
investing is a no-call strike game you
know if i were a baseball player
and i only like pitches two inches above
my navel
you know some guy could learn that and
he could pitch me you know three or four
inches below that and i get called out
on strikes because i never find a pitch
i like
you can get call out on strikes in
baseball you have to
you have to swing at pitches that you
you don't even necessarily like
particularly after the count gets to two
strikes in business
you don't have to swing on anything you
can sit there and the paper says general
motors at 68 or it says general electric
at 115 or says general dynamics at 63.
and if you don't like those prices you
don't have to swing you can wait there
day after day after day after day and
there are no called strikes
now when you swing when you decide to
buy something
then you know if you swing and miss it's
a strike but it's a marvelous game to be
in because there are no called strikes
and you can simply wait
for that one time in a month or six
months or a year
or two or three years when you really
know what you're doing where you like
the price
where you like the people running the
business and then you swing and you only
need a few swings in your lifetime
how do you turn failure into a plus uh
and
it's true when i was at the university
of nebraska
one day i was reading the daily
nebraskan and it said
in room 300 or something
at three o'clock there will be this
panel of three
uh uh professors here at the
university and they're going to award
the nathan gold scholarship i don't know
whether you still you still have that
around
and at the time uh it said it would give
you five hundred dollars to go to the
graduate school of your choice i don't
know whether it's
changed an amount but but that that was
it so i read this
and i went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was
and i walked in the room and there were
the professors
and i was the only student that showed
up i mean it really got to them i mean
they they were stuck they you know they
kept waiting and looking at their watch
and hoping there would be more
candidates
but there no one came in so i won 500
by by default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up
and so here i was i had 500 to go toward
any it wasn't it wasn't the limit as any
any graduate school
for a master's degree so i applied to
harvard my dad wanted me to
and uh i shortly heard from harvard
and they said go to chicago and meet
this fellow running
that who interviews applicants from the
midwest
so i got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and i
spent about 10 hours on the burlington
going to chicago
then i transferred to another little
inner urban train to go up to this
country day school where this fellow was
the headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for harvard
and i got there and after about 10
minutes he
he said better think about something
else that uh
you know he uh come back later on i was
i was 19 at the time and
uh i looked about 12 you know and and i
and i acted about eight uh it was not a
great combination
uh but so he he said forget it
so i spent uh took the little interurban
train back to chicago and i took the
10-hour train back to oman all the time
i think you know what do i tell my
parents you know it's kind of
embarrassing
uh but it was it was the luckiest thing
ever happened to me
i because
if i'd gone to harvard i would have gone
to a two-year business school
i i instead applied to columbia where i
could graduate in one year and get a
master's degree
luckily that by the accident of it and
being in the nebraska national guard
which did not get called up for the
korean war
i missed going in the korean war
i
i got to meet ben graham and which had
an enormous effect on me subsequently
and i probably got my wife that way
because she was going to northwestern
and i was able to put on sort of a full
court press because i got out in one
year
and otherwise uh she'd she'd have met
some other guy i mean i i got her before
the competition showed up and
uh so it worked out wonderfully it
couldn't have worked out better
and that's been that's been my life
basically i mean it the
things you know you will get some
disappointments you know
uh but the future is what counts that'd
be fun
if i knew every decision i was going to
make was going to be perfect it would
not be as much fun be like playing golf
and knowing you're going to hit
a hole in one on every hole you wouldn't
play golf
if every time you got out a tee you just
took a swing and the ball ended up in
the hole you know
be fun for a few days you can get on tv
but
it the game would not be any fun uh so
it's
failure you know and i wouldn't even
consider them failures but
they're mistakes or whatever you want to
call it they're they're part of the game
and in the end you know you go on and
and
we've made plenty of mistakes in
business we'll make plenty more
and then you know the babe ruth and
you know for a long time it subsequently
got eclipsed by
a few fellows but uh he held the record
for strikeouts you know so the
record for home runs and was highest
baseball player until
the modern era came along uh so it's
it's part of the game if you take big
swings you know you
you may you may you're going to miss
sometimes i like to read more than most
kids
i really like to read a lot my auntie
gave me a copy of the
world almanac and that was heaven to me
and i can still tell you that
almost population was 214 0006 in 1930.
some numbers just kind of stick with you
and very early probably when i was seven
or so i took this book out of the
benson library called a thousand ways to
make a thousand dollars
and one of the ways in this book was
having
penny weighing machines
[Music]
and i sat and calculated how much it
would cost to buy the first weighing
machine and how long
it would take for the profit for that
one to buy another one i would sit there
and
create these compound interest tables to
figure out how long it would take me to
have a weighing machine for every person
in the world
first books i read on investment were
actually in my dad's office
[Music]
pretty soon i read all the books in the
office and read some of them more than
once
a few years ago i went to amazon and
sure enough they had this manual there
so
while reliving my youth other guys were
going to amazon probably and
and uh buying old playboys or something
but i bought old
movies manuals instead and when i got
out of school
i started selling stocks i was 20 years
old at the time and
looked about 16 and acted about 12 so i
was not the most
impressive sales person anybody ever met
but what i would do was i i went through
page by page
looking for possibly undervalued stocks
what other
habits did you cultivate in your 20s and
your 30s that you now see
as being foundational to your success as
a business person
well i i knew a lot
about what i do uh when i was 20. i mean
i i
really read a lot and i aspired to learn
everything that i could about the
subject
so intellectually i knew a lot i did not
know a lot about human behavior i mean
that
that you can't learn really out of
reading books but it's
it's very important to understand people
and uh i say to the students
you know just imagine you could buy or
you
or you could be given 10 percent of the
future earnings
of one person that you know among
everybody you know
now you're going to pick the person
that's the smartest i'm going to pick
the person that can
dance the best or that you can run the
fastest or anything like that that's the
right height
no anything you're gonna you're gonna
pick the person that has the right
habits that that
is cheerful generous gives other people
credit for what they do
you know and when you look at all of the
qualities that you admire in other
people
which would cause you to pick that
person say to yourself which of those
qualities
can't i have myself because they are
you know you determine whether you have
them so just write them down on the
piece
of paper who is the person that you
admire the most or like the best
why do i like them and just write down
and then say
which of these can i do myself and the
truth is you can do them
and then you also if you really want to
carry it to the next extreme you pick
the person you dislike the most
and why do you dislike that person you
know and you know
they always they're never fair about
things basically they always claim
more credit than they're doing
everything and write down those
qualities
and say if you dislike that some other
person why in the world would you want
to have those yourself
so you should get rid of those and it's
it's a pretty simple thing to do
but you want to be the person that if
you could pick
your best friend you know that you would
have the same qualities
i'm 72. i'm getting social security now
so i'm you know i
i should be in florida you know pushing
shuffleboard around or something of the
sort but
but but i do what i can do anything in
the world i want to do but what i want
to do is run berkshire hathaway now why
do i want to run it that way i get to
paint my own painting
you know i go down there every day and i
feel like you know i feel like
michelangelo there
you know working on the sistine chapel
or something nobody else may think it's
a great painting but i get to paint my
own penny
i do not have people second guessing me
i do not have
people saying why don't you use a little
more red paint than blue paint why don't
you paint a seascape instead of a
landscape
i get to do my own thing i get the it's
it's
it's a form of creativity it's exactly
like
somebody feels it's a professional
golfer or somebody feels it's a painter
they're not doing it for the money
primarily uh
they're doing it because they like doing
something well we've got a company
flight safety with
trains more pilots than anybody in the
world flight safety
is run by an 85 year old man al yoshi
al started the company with ten thousand
dollars in 1951
it now trains four or five times as many
pilots as uh
non-military pilots as any as anybody in
the world
and he is there at 85 and then it's a
matter of public record he's got a
billion dollars worth of berkshire
shares
he works seven days a week he loves it
and he loves it for the same reason
that i love what i do he gets to do it
his way
he buys these big simulators that you
train pilots in
he doesn't have to check with me as to
whether to spend 15 million dollars for
a simulator
he doesn't ask me he knows so much more
about it than you know that i do
why in the world would he ask me well i
can't tell what kind of a plane i'm in
you know when i'm flying around and
and al is spending a couple hundred
million dollars a year on
simulators uh she's spending berkshire
hathaway money
and he never checks with alma he's never
had to come to omaha
uh for any kind of meetings he runs his
own business
and that's what he loves in life and i
let him do it i mean that's my
contribution to it is
is really turning loose his energies and
you know they were properly directed
before we bought the company seven or
eight years ago why do why should i
think that you know he couldn't keep
running it after that and like i say at
85 he's still running it
and that feeling of ownership is really
extraordinary and it's so much better i
mean it's the way i like to work
uh and it's the way you know it's the
way uh susan jock likes to work it's the
way al yoshi likes to work
you're lucky in life if you can find
your passion i tell the students you
know what
you may have to take a job or two you
got to eat
but never give up searching for the job
that's your passion
try to find the job that you would have
if you were independently rich
that's the job i have and when you find
that job the job that causes you
to be excited every day and forget about
the pain
and where you associate with people you
love doing what you love it doesn't get
any better than that
my partner charlie is 89 and we were
talking about that this weekend you know
i'm 82 he's 89.
we do what we love every day with people
we love you know and they seem to like
us okay so
you know it how can it be any better and
just
cost of living does not equate the
standard of living and the standard of
living is you know
achieving what you want to achieve
working with people that you love and
you don't need that much money aside i
love to ride around in a private plate i
will
totally acknowledge that leave it
leaving that out you know i basically
you know leaving out taxes and charity
and things like that i could live on
easily live on a hundred thousand
dollars a year and
it and i wouldn't live i wouldn't live
better
if i had eight houses if i hadn't you
know a 400 foot yacht or anything of the
sword
i've been on 400-foot yachts and i've
been a lot of fancy houses
but i'm in a house that i bought 55
years ago
it's warm in the winter it's cool in the
summer
it has everything i wanted plus it has
all kinds of good memories you know
my kids have good thoughts about it i
can't imagine
living any better i paid thirty one
thousand five hundred dollars for it i
could pay 31 million
for a house and and it wouldn't it
wouldn't do for me what this present
house does
one of the things you do in your annual
report which has become a classic
is you will discuss what went wrong
like dexter and what you and how and
and and what you learned from it tough
tough to do well it's it's it's very
important to recognize this thing i mean
if something but it goes around and says
you know i never made a mistake i mean
you quit listening to them i mean
you know they're in the dream world so
so
facing up to it uh it's it's a little
like in
in in terms of discussing issues you
should be able to discuss the other
fellows position
just as well as you can discuss your own
so i mean that's part of thinking well
and and certainly part of making good
decisions in business
is recognizing the poor decisions you've
made and
why they were poor and and that doesn't
mean you never do the same thing i mean
it because sometimes it was a freak
situation but
but i have made lots of mistakes i'm
going to make more mistakes
uh but you know babe ruth struck out a
lot of times i mean
it's the name of the game that you do it
you don't want to expect perfection in
yourself
you want to strive to do your best but
but it's too demanding to expect
perfection in yourself and it does some
good to recognize them and not start
trying to go around kidding people about
them is there a meaningful distinction
to be drawn between
making money out of investment and
making money out of speculation it's
always a bet isn't it it's always a
gamble no it isn't a gamble there is a
real distinction that basically
it it's subjective but an investment
attitude you look to
the asset itself to produce the return
so if i buy a farm
and i expect it to produce eighty
dollars an acre for me
in terms of its revenue from corn and
soybeans and it cost me six hundred
dollars
i'm looking at i'm looking at the return
from the farm itself i'm not looking at
the price of the farm every day or every
week or every year
on the other hand if i buy a stock and i
hope it goes up next week to me that's
pure speculation
shortly after i met bill gates bill's
dad asked each of us to write down on a
piece of paper one word that would best
describe
what it helped us the most bill and i
without any collaboration at all
he wrote the word focus
well focus has always been a strong part
of my
personality if i get interested in
something i get really interested
if i get interested in new subject i
want to read about it i want to talk
about it and i want to meet people that
are involved in it
if somebody told me 10 years ago what
was going to happen in the next 10 years
we could have made a lot of money in the
bond market together you know but
but it it's there's always a reason
afterwards tomorrow's paper will say
stocks went down today because of you
know but they didn't they didn't write
it this morning's paper
stocks are going to go down today
you have to know what you don't know and
you have to make sure
that what you don't know isn't all
important i mean you know if there's
four boxes there
you want to get to what is knowable
and and and and and and which uh is
favorable
and there's things that you'll miss out
on because they belong in
other three boxes one of which will be
favorable
another one the favorable and uh the
fact that you're missing out on ninety
percent of the stuff
doesn't really make any difference if
the ten percent you do is right
if success is contingent on a good plan
excellent edu
um you know education and execution in a
driven mindset
what do you think makes businesses fall
apart
um when all of these factors have been
met
and con some businesses are just tough
i mean a significant percentage you know
the restaurants
that open up this year are going to fail
i mean there are a lot of a lot of tough
businesses
i've always said if you want to be
regarded as a great business person
find a great business and
there's a huge difference i mean it does
make a difference i
use this analogy when i when i got out
of columbia one of my best friends was
terrific talent and uh
he went to work in the steel business
and
he did okay but it was the wrong
business to be in
it's very important to get on the right
train i mean you want to you want to get
on a train
that's going to go 90 miles an hour and
not one that's going to go 30 miles an
hour and you're going to try to figure
out how to you know push it along a
little faster
so it really does make a huge difference
uh
and and there are some businesses
that are inherently uh there's far more
opportunity and than others so
you want to give a lot of thought to
what train you're getting on and
uh i owned a half interest when i was i
don't know 21 or 22
in a service station uh a sinclair
service station with a pal of mine in
the national guard
it was a lousy business you know we had
a guy right next to us he kept selling
more
gallons of gas than we did he would cut
our prices and everything
i mean i i don't i don't care if you
know if you're a combination of steve
jobs and
larry ellison and everyone else you're
not going to succeed if you got a guy
selling
gas below cost next year so you know
what it's important to get on the right
train
it takes three qualities essentially to
do well
and extremely well actually in this
country it takes intelligence
it takes energy and it takes integrity
and i say if you don't have integrity
you know if we don't want to hire
somebody that's got intelligence and
energy if they don't have integrity we'd
rather hire somebody that's dumb and
lazy
if they don't have integrity because
they probably will never get around to
cheating us or doing something
and integrity is absolutely an option
you know
you may not be able to throw a football
60 yards and you know you may not be
able to run the hundred and
in nine eight you know you may not be
able to think three pointers from
but you can choose
where you stand on the integrity scale
you can't
you weren't born wired one way or the
other that is an absolute choice you
make
i was wondering if you have any stock
tips for any of the students you know
who are all trying to uh make make a
little living
i didn't think they taught that at
georgetown
they now they the best the best
investment i ever met well
i i bought a book in 1949 by a fellow
named ben graham called the intelligent
investor
i i don't remember what i paid but aside
from what i paid for my two marriage
licenses that was the best investment i
ever made
and uh it's very important
to have the right framework you need you
need
you need to have an approach to
investing that sound and
graham's approach is is simple uh
but some people uh
adopt to it and and which i did
immediately and and most people don't
but if you have the right philosophy you
will find
opportunities uh as you go through the
next
20 30 40 50 years and and frankly you're
most likely to find them
uh when in periods like five years ago
when we were having
the panic i mean that uh
stocks sell at silly prices from time to
time
most stocks at one time or another sell
at very silly prices
uh and it doesn't take
a high iq to figure out that they're
cheap
but it does take a temperament that's
willing to step
up and actually act i tell people if
they're going in the investment business
if you got 160 iq sell 30 points to
somebody else because you won't need it
i mean that
i mean i figured out very early you
don't have to be that smart of this
business which is fortunate
but you do have to have the right
temperament and you have to be able to
ignore
what other people are saying and and
simply look at the facts
and decide is this stock which is
selling it
x worth 2x and occasionally you'll find
things like that and if when you don't
find them you don't do anything
so that's my generalized stock tip no
names
i should mention one thing about reading
uh
it was at the library here at columbia
that i wish i spent probably more time
than
any other uh student i lived there
practically
but you know i pulled the book out there
happened to be who's an american that
told me something about my professor
benjamin graham and then i looked up and
i went to the library and i said i want
to look learn more about this because i
learned this over here
that changed my whole life you know we
own geico now
uh because of uh of that librarian
directing me
to some other book and then following
through on that
it's the chance i i i read about
one-fifth the pace that bill does but i
still spend five or six hours a day
reading i mean it's just
you can learn so much i particularly
love biography just
you know to be able to live the lives of
these people that have been
seeing so extraordinary the lessons and
the you know the discouragements they
face just everything about it so i did
you can't get enough of reading how
would you advise people who aren't
necessarily going into a career field in
which you would make a
large base salary such as like medicine
or
something like that maybe performing
arts or
music how would you advise us to
keep up financially with the rest of the
world
well it is true that a market system
uh does not pay as well in some
in some activities as as
might seem appropriate for the
importance of those activities the
society
just take teaching for example i mean
teaching does not pay well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as
as interested in who you're the teachers
of your children are is who your
accountant is or you know
uh whatever or who's winning the
heavyweight title of the world or that
sort of thing but
but it doesn't it doesn't pay well and
and
it's a fundamental choice uh whether
you're going to go into something
that for many people it'd be it'd be a
fundamental choice whether you're going
to go into something you love or
something to
to try and make a lot of money i think
that generally it pays to go with what
you love
and i think that
it's very hard to find people when they
get to be my age
who say they're on that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile
but they're terribly sad they made that
choice because they didn't make a lot of
money i i don't think
anybody's ever ever said that to me that
they wish they'd gone into something
else where they
were uncomfortable doing it or didn't
enjoy it didn't feel very productive but
made a lot of money
so i don't think you'll find that so i
would i would
i would go to work i would go to work in
whatever turns you on
it may turn out that it'll it'll be more
profitable than than you can think but
almost everybody here will make enough
money unless they get some terrible
habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is is uh is pretty darn good i
mean
it is it's not necessary to have
huge amounts of money in order enjoy
yourself i enjoyed myself when i was
at my ten thousand dollars and i live in
the same house that i lived in when i
was making it
when i had about that i bought it 41
years ago i like the house then i like
the house now
i mean if you think about it if you have
a reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating mcdonald's so we're we're to
push
on on on food i mean you know in fact i
hope it's dairy queen actually in may
and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order and
we both can afford it uh you know you'll
you'll wear the same clothes i wear i'll
pay more for my suits but as soon as i
put them on they look cheap on me so
we'll look about the same and uh
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's
it's warm in winter and it's cool in
summer and it's comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and then and
what difference does it make if you have
50 more rooms or you know guest houses
or all that
you know it'll probably just bring you
problems i mean you have to worry about
the
about the greens keeper or something
when you get through so i
i i have been in the houses of people uh
where the houses are worth
oh probably 200 times uh what my house
is worth and
i would not be any happier in those
houses at all in fact i'd be less happy
i just have one more thing to
to worry about and you know the dozens
of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah
uh we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you'll probably drive a
better car i drive a car it's about
eight years old i don't know what it's
worth now but
it gets me around fine i mean i'm
perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll we'll work on the same computer
pretty much
the only difference will be how we
travel long distances
you know i will fly in a plane that's
more comfortable than than flying
southwest airlines or something
which i've got nothing against but that
that's the one real big difference
and other than that i do what i like
every day i hope you you'll do what you
like every day to do
and i work with nice people i hope you
work with nice people
uh and that's there's 24 hours in the
day and those are
where the hours go so great wealth
uh is the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and and to trade
a decent income and something you love
doing and something where you feel
worthwhile doing it
for huge wealth where you'd
trade off a lot of your principles uh
would be a terrible mistake i was very
lucky in life
uh if you tell me who your heroes are i
will
make a pretty good prediction about how
what you're going to do and i i
i had the right heroes i was very lucky
in life and
my heroes never let me down and started
with my dad
and then i had others in business and so
i have had
great teachers some formal teachers some
that were just
informal teachers teachers by instinct
or example
and if i hadn't had those
uh you know my life i'm sure would have
been very different
i was lucky that i got started early i
mean it always helps if you get started
early
and and my dad happened to be in an
investment business so i would go down
his office on
saturdays and so at age probably seven
or something i started reading these
books that were around the place and
so i had a 15-year jump on many people
in
in a sense and that that helped a lot
and and i was always fascinated by them
i knew what i wanted to do early and i
think that's a
that's a huge advantage too and then you
don't need
you don't need a lot of brains in this
business i mean i've always said if
you've got an iq of 160 give away 30
points to somebody else because you
don't need it in investments what you do
need is emotional stability
you have to you have to be able to think
independently and you have to be
you have to be when you come to a
conclusion you have to really not care
what other people say and
and just follow the facts and follow
your reasoning and and that's
that's tough for a lot of people but
that part i think i was just lucky with
i was born that way in terms of emotions
it's
a truism that investing emotions are
your enemy
absolutely that uh when the market's
good if you feel good don't if you feel
bad you should probably do it
right but uh how uh how how did you
uh what was that extra thing where uh
so many will acknowledge that and yet we
saw in the current crisis
they they panicked why you went into
seemingly uh potential disasters like ge
and
goldman sachs i can't really tell you
the i mean i didn't learn in school or
anything i just
it never bothered me if people disagreed
with what i thought
as long as i felt i knew the facts i
mean there's a whole bunch of things i
don't know think about
i just stay away from those so i stay
within what i call my circle of
confidence you know
that tom watson said it best he said you
know he said he said i'm no genius but
i'm smart in spots and i stay around
those spots well
i try and stay around those spots and i
i just don't have a
a problem if if somebody says you know
you're wrong on something i just i go
back and look at the facts and
and i think that i think that really is
much more important frankly than than
having a few points of iq or or having
an extra course or two in in
school or anything of the sort you need
emotional stability if you look around
you at the people you admire
you know they have certain qualities i
mean you've got you've got friends why
do you like them you know
generally you know that they generally
they have an upbeat
attitude on life generally they're
generous people they're humorous people
they're people that do more than their
share
they're people that are thinking about
something nice they can do for you
and all of those qualities attract you
and none of those are
are innate at birth i mean you you can
acquire those
and then there's other people that turn
you off you know and and
uh they have habits they take credit for
things they didn't do they don't show up
on time whatever it may be they're a
little dishonest about things
and if you're looking at your life at
a young age like you are and you can
choose what kind of a person you can be
why not be the person you admire rather
than the person you can't stand it's so
simple
so just write down the qualities you
like
take your take your five best friends
why do you like them and just write down
those qualities
and you will find there's no quality
there that you can't have yourself
and similarly with the five people you
can't stand to be around
but those put those things down to turn
you off about those people
and if they turn you off about them why
should you possess them you're gonna
it's it's so simple uh you know
it's it's not it's not it's not like
some something complicated that you
think you should be learning with an
advanced
no but it's it's enormously important
to have people work with you in life
right they're going to work with you in
life if they like you
you know and they may occasionally i
mean if you're in the army or something
you know
you may work for somebody that you don't
like but by and large
you're going to get the best out of
people if they feel good about you
and it's just so easy but you've got to
develop the habits early because
you can't say i'm gonna suddenly become
a terribly attractive person when i'm
60.
it just doesn't work that way so pick up
the right habits now
and i will guarantee you if you actually
just write down those qualities
and think about it you will find you can
have every one of the attractive
qualities get rid of the ones that are
are negative and your life will be
different all of you in this room
have the brains to do extremely well in
life
you've all got the energy to do
extremely well on life and then the
question is how do you apply it
if you've got a 200 horsepower motor you
get 200 horsepower out of it
you get your full potential or do you
get 100 horsepower or 50 horsepower
now there's two things that can hold you
back
in getting the full horsepower out of
your your engine whatever it may be all
of you have big enough engines
and one of those is a lack of education
but that probably isn't going to happen
to very many people in this room
if you did have a lack of education if
you didn't have a chance to get a decent
education in life
it wouldn't make any difference what
that potential was because you'd never
unlock it
but the second most important thing and
equally as important
is in terms of the habits that you
develop in terms of what you do with
yourself
when we hire people we look for three
qualities
we look for integrity we look for
intelligence
and we look for energy but if they don't
have the first one integrity
the other two will kill you because if
you're hiring somebody without integrity
you really want to be dumb and lazy
don't you i mean you know
last thing in the world you want forms
to be smart and energetic so
smart and energetic only goes with
integrity
but the nice thing about
you know you make your own decision on
that you can't change
your iq or how far you control football
or how high you can jump
or the color of your hair very easily
but you can
elect to have integrity that matches
anybody else's and if you match that
with intelligence which you have and
energy which you have
uh you will get an extraordinary result
and you'd be very foolish to sell me ten
percent of yourself for fifty thousand
on the other hand
if you don't match it with that your
potential will in a significant part
go unused over the years i've developed
a better understanding of
human nature i can learn a lot about
investments out of a book but
i don't think you can learn as much
about human beings
you really need some experiences and i'm
wiser in that respect than i was
40 or 50 years ago even though i can't
rattle off numbers the same way i used
to be able to
if you buy a business if you buy a farm
you know
you go up and look you know every couple
weeks to see how far the corn is up and
you know you worry too much about
whether somebody says this is going to
be a year low prices because
exports are being affected or anything
like that you know you buy a farm
and you hold it for i've got one farm
that i bought in the 1980s and
my son runs it but i've been there once
you know i mean it it it doesn't grow
faster if i go and stare at it you know
i can't cheer for it you know
more effort more effort or something
like that and i know there's going to be
some years when prices are going to be
good and some when the prices aren't
going to be good i know there's years
when yields will be better than others
but about the farm and and
if it just doesn't i don't care about
economic predictions on
anything of the sort i do care that over
over the years it's well tended to in
terms of rotating crops and
i hope yields get better which they
generally have in fact
that farm 100 years ago would have
probably produced
30 bushels maybe 35 bushels of corn per
acre
now in a good year you know it'd be 200
i mean
we really made progress in this country
that's one reason commodity prices have
go back a couple hundred years they've
moved so little
is because we've just gotten better and
better at whether it's
cotton or whether it's it's corn or
soybeans or
all kinds of things and you and i have
benefited from that
and so apple's kind of like a farm well
it's a it's a long-term
investment and and if you owned
if you own the the best auto dealership
in town
uh the best brand and had somebody
good running he wouldn't drop by every
day and say you know how many people
have come in today or
you know i think interest rates are
going up a little maybe that'll slow
down our sales or anything
no you buy it knowing there's 365 days a
year and
you're going to own it for 20 years so
that's 7 300 days and you know they're
gonna
things are going to be different from
day to day and year to year
you shouldn't buy it if the day-to-day
stuff is important if you look around
the world
at the people that succeed and the
people that
other people want to work with the
natural leaders it isn't because they
have the highest iq or they can kick a
football the furthest or anything like
that
they're people that you want to work
with i mean i've got a wonderful friend
named tom murphy i know
i would do anything for him you know
he's never going to ask me to do it but
i mean i want it
but i want to do it i i want to do it i
mean he's done so many things for me and
then
and you know i you know he didn't have
to pay me to do it or anything of the
sort that
though that's what you want to you want
to look for that and then you want to be
that
you will move in the direction of the
people that you associate with so i
it's important to associate with people
that are better than yourself and
actually the most important decision
many of you make not all of you will be
the spouse you're choosing
and uh you really
you want to associate with people who
are the kind of person you'd like to be
you'll you'll move in that direction and
the most important person by far
in that respect is your spouse i can't
overemphasize how important that is and
you're right
the friends you have uh they will form
you as you go
through life and uh
make some good friends keep them for the
rest of your life but
have them be people that you admire as
well as like them
as a general matter as a one piece of
specific finance
financial advice i would say
you know avoid credit cards just forget
about them
uh we're in various businesses that
issue credit cards the american public
loves credit cards but if you start
revolving debt on credit cards you're
going to be paying
18 or 20 percent and you can't make
progress in your financial life going
around borrowing money at 18 or 20
percent
you can make a lot of money by lending
it out at 18 or 20
over time you know if you can find
anybody that's good that
will borrow from you but you don't want
to be on the side of the equation
that's always behind in life uh
you know i was lucky i'd saved about ten
thousand dollars by the time i got out
of school that ten thousand dollars was
really worth millions i might have
earned later on because after you get a
family and everything the
expenses roll in but but those were my
tools to work with but it was only
because i was ahead of the game
if you're behind the game by ten
thousand dollars at some point and
paying 18 or 20 percent
interest on it you will never you know
you'll never get out of it so
the trick i've got a partner that says
all i want to know is where i'm going to
die so i'll never go there
you know and uh and that's true in
financial matters as well you want to
figure out where you don't want to be
ahead of time and avoid that and i get
about a dozen letters a day
from people who are having terrible
problems and there are two reasons why
they have terrible problems
one is a number of them have had health
problems of some sort i mean they have
really been hit by some or somebody in
their family has been hit by some kind
of catastrophic
illness and that is a you know it's a
terrible thing to happen to any family
and they get in they run up bills they
can't pay and and
really only society can solve that one
uh
uh in terms of protecting people against
that that's just plain bad luck
but the other one is from people who run
up credit card debt
and they're facing bankruptcy or they've
been through bankruptcy once before
and they owe a whole bunch of money and
they can't they can't even pay the
interest let alone pay any principal
and half of my letters come from people
like that and that that that problem is
avoidable
catastrophic illness is not but but
credit card debt is something you bring
on yourself
and it's way better it's way easier
to stay out of trouble than to get out
of trouble financially and
and i will guarantee you if you run a
big credit card that
you will be in trouble uh probably the
rest of your life
in terms of uh your financial situation
on the other hand if you get ahead of
the game
uh even it's on a very modest scale
so that money is coming in from
investing
and you're you're people owe you money
or equities owe you ownership
uh you'll be way out of the game
compared to paying it uh
being always being paying your creditors
every month
so my advice to you is if you can't pay
for it
don't buy it i have constructed a
business
that fits me it's kind of crazy
to spend your life painting if you're
painting a subject you don't want to
look at
i've gotten to paint my own painting in
business on an
unlimited canvas in a way
[Music]
it's a different sort of place
i work with great group of people that
make my life very easy and
take good care of me
we have 25 people in the office and
if you go back it's the exact same 25
the exact same ones
we don't have any committees at
berkshire we don't have a public
relations department we don't investor
relations we don't have a general
counsel
we don't have a human relations
department we just don't go for anything
that
people do just as a matter of form
it's exactly the life i like and
it's not work to me it's just a form of
play basically
you both have several managers working
under you so i was wondering what are
some steps
that a new entrant into the job market
can take to accelerate their journey
towards an upper
level management position yeah well one
thing i will tell you that i didn't
realize when i was
getting out of school is how much the
unusual person
will jump out at you i mean you know and
it isn't because they got
200 iqs or anything like that it's
really because just how they behave
you know what they bring the energy they
bring the commitment they bring the
quality of how they do things how they
treat the people around them all kinds
of things but
you will jump out much more than you
might anticipate
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do
is whether you like it or not get very
comfortable it may take a while with
public speaking for example i mean that
that's a an asset that will last you
50 or 60 years and it's a liability if
you don't like doing it or uncomfortable
doing it that also
will last you 50 or 60 years and it's a
necessary skill
but a lot of the skills are just human
skills if you get the best out of people
around you
that's a rare talent and it it doesn't
it doesn't correlate with iq it
correlates with a
you know an attitude and uh toward the
world and toward other people and
it's a talent that if you work at early
and you're really conscious about it
you know you don't have to show up other
people you know you have to be smarter
than me or anything
you want to bring out the best in them
it will pay huge dividends
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate
you how do you deal with failure and
what's your advice to young
entrepreneurs
like me in this case especially with
regards to failure and how to approach
it yeah well
if if you fail you really do dust
yourself off and
you know get right back in i mean you're
going to fail at some things
uh uh you're going to have some human
relationships that don't work out
uh you know fairly significant number of
people get divorced i mean
you know that's a very big decision to
have turn out badly but
uh i think if you study
almost everybody and read read kay's
book you know personal history
and you'll everybody fails at some
things i mean you know particularly
particularly when you're younger i mean
you know you do have less experience in
evaluating humans and you know and just
knowing about whatever it may be
businesses uh
but you know it it is not fatal i mean
if you're healthy
and you live in this particular living
in this country there's going to be
there's going to be an opportunity that
comes along
uh uh i got turned down for the harvard
business school uh when i was
when i got out of the university
nebraska you know and i remember you
know
i went to chicago to get interviewed
this is when you traveled on the train
and so i spent 10 hours going there and
this fellow looked at me and
about 10 minutes he said you know forget
it belle
and now i've got to go back on the train
10 hours and think what am i going to
tell my dad
tell my dad i mean my dad always told me
i could do anything and everything
now i've just got just gotten turned
down uh you know
but it turned out that one of the best
things ever happened to me because then
i went to columbia where
ben graham was it in fact it probably
even affected who i married because i
took a one-year course at columbia and
said two years at harvard and she might
have found some other guy
during that time almost everything in my
life
that looked like a failure has either
turned
usually it's turned into a success i
mean it it
the world isn't over you know if you
have bad luck in health that
that's tough i mean that there's just no
there's just no getting away i've been
lucky on that but
but the other kind of things if you're
healthy and you're
bright and you know you've got decades
ahead of you
you know if something goes wrong if you
find yourself working for the wrong
employer and they're you know
they're doing things you don't approve
of or they're not treating you fairly
you know the world isn't over yet you
know you just go out
and find somebody else if you want to
sign up for the entire billionaire
mindset series for free and get the
companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link right there next to me i
think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there